hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to
talk today about a subject that comes up
quite often and for which I'm not sure I
have the right answer and the question
is how often should we listen to the
same material or read the same lesson
how much time should we spend on one
lesson before you move on and in my
previous video I pointed out that in my
Greek I noticed that I have listened to
some of these lessons 40 50 times and
that I try to in the beginning stages of
my learning do a lot of repetitive
listening and reading and that later on
I tend to read material maybe only once
in other words I go from a very
intensive form of listening and reading
and repetitive to a more extensive now
there was a comment that all that video
from a person who is a teacher and said
that their experience has been they did
a an experiment and they had half the
class a very intensively study fifteen
lessons I say that the whole course was
60 lessons long so they had the class
one group half of them studied the
fifteen lessons very intensively and the
other group plowed forward to do all 60
and it turned out that at the end of the
first period that they looked at them
obviously the group that had been very
intensively studying the 15 lessons
performed better than the group that was
moving forward more quickly but at the
end of the period the group that had
covered more material was better in
every way pronunciation fluency
vocabulary you name it which tends to
suggest that we are better off to plow
ahead and not worry too much about what
we understand not try to ace things not
try to you know create the sort of
repetitious you know awareness and so
forth so I'm kind of struggling with my
grief for example I have been under the
impression that particularly since I'm
going to Greece in in a little over a
month or maybe in six weeks and I want
to be able to say something and I feel
it's repetitive listening helps me
get a handle of the language but I'm
questioning whether that's really right
maybe I am better served by just plowing
ahead on link I look up words that I
don't know they show up letter later on
highlighted in yellow I'm forever moving
on to new material a lot of basic
vocabulary and phrasing is naturally
gonna repeat but I'm pushing forward
rather than worrying so much about in
graining these phrases in my mind if I
follow the example of this person maybe
I'm better served by moving faster I
know for a fact that I've always felt
that that one of the biggest mm faults
that language learners have is that they
stay too long with learner material so I
have tended to say okay two months maybe
I mean it depends on the language with
Romanian because the vocabulary is so
similar to Italian very relatively
quickly I could move into authentic
material in Greek where there's maybe
only 10 15 % familiar vocabulary it's
very difficult still for me to read say
newspapers so it depends on the language
but I think we should perhaps be pushing
ourselves and I'm gonna do this now with
Marguerite push myself a little bit more
to move away from the familiar lessons
trying to nail down that extra you know
10-15 percent of of comprehension and
push myself more towards newer and and
and perhaps more challenging material at
any rate I thought that was a very
interesting comment and it it gave me
some food for thought and I would be
interested in your reactions or your
experience thank you for listening and
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe bye for now
[Music]